in et chantal sont venus voir et écouter
comment robert combas l'artiste peintre
chante georges brassens
qui fait au moins deux mètres sur deux
et le titre c'est les amoureux des bancs
publics
bancs publics dans tous
les partis non voyons alors chantal lui
raconte
la femme est sûre
qui s'embrassent is décote et puis à
côté
il représentait une forme de rébellion à
l'époque il avait son franc parler qui
tranchait sur la manière de parler de ce
moment là et ça m'est resté le mieux
bien les uns selon
le camp c'est fait avec karoui vois ça
m'oblige donc à décrire ce que je vois
bon c'est pas toujours très simple mais
la whey mais le faire et ce que ça soit
hyper colorés quoi des gens moi j'adore
je situe les traits de brassens de
mémoire et ça me permet de voir tout ce
qu'on peut tirer d'un avec de
l'imagination avec de la couleur avec 2
et admirent les bancs publics pauvre
martin quand je pense à fernande des
portraits de chansons plus ou moins
facile à décrire le gorille est presque
un exercice périlleux
brassens chanteur irrévérencieux et
combas artiste peintre punk ce serait
bien entendu robert et comme je pense
comme georges brassens il date quand
même de la tendresse et les facétieux il
s'amuse beaucoup ils pensent qu'ils y
passent par la tête et avec sa façon de
voir les choses mais toujours à quai
petit sourire en coin et ça c'est très
plaisant
sur les aires éternelle de brassens fait
interprété par jean claude vannier à
travers une vingtaine d'oeuvres robert
combas jouer avec le chanteur sa
moustache sa pipe refusant de le mettre
sur un piédestal je cite d'où il se
casserait la gueule
[Musique]